hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring in this video we're gonna have
a preview to the huge a CT math review
video course that I just put together
for you but this is a one of the lessons
of the 65 different lessons in the video
course so if the math section they CT is
something that you struggle with this
video course could help you boost your
score and it goes through 65 concepts
it's three and a half hours worth of
video there's teaching sections and
there's opportunities for you to
practice we go through the examples
together so if this is something you
struggle with check out the video of
course I have links for that but in the
meantime enjoy this preview I'm gonna
have two others like it so I'll see you
in the video okay in this lesson we're
going to talk about averages and means
so this is definitely something you want
to understand on the ECT they usually
test this in a couple different formats
let's go through it the first thing you
want to know is the formula for the
average or the mean the mean is just
another name for the average and so what
you do when you calculate the average is
you total up whatever it is that you're
working with and you divide by how many
of those that there are and that's your
average now on that ect they may have
you solve for the average they may have
you solve for the number of items they
may have you solve for the total they
may have you solve for one of the
missing quantities so as long as you
know the formula you can substitute in
what you know and solve for the unknown
so let's go through two examples and
you'll get a better feel for how this
works so the first example is a little
bit more straightforward example it just
says what is the average number of fish
caught by the fishermen and there's a
table over here it's got Bob John Alex
and Sam it shows you the number of fish
that they caught maybe it's like a
fishing competition something like that
and we're just trying to figure out what
the average is so go ahead and pause the
video and go ahead and see if you can
solve it and then we'll go through it
together okay so the first thing you
want to do is using our average formulas
we want to total up the number of fish
caught so let's go ahead and do that so
we've got let's see 8 plus 2 is 10 okay
and 6 plus 4 is 10 so 10 plus 10 is 20
so it's a total of 20 so that's your
total right here divided by how many
people are in this competition there's 4
and so that's going to give you your
average which is 20 divided by 4 which
means it's 5
fish on average per person so the answer
is five now that one was pretty easy
let's do a little bit more challenging
one example number two it says if you
have scored in 8776 88 and 92 on the
last four tests what do you need to
score on the fifth test to have an
overall average of 90 okay now this is a
pretty popular question both in your
class as well as on a CT people are
wondering what do I need to do to get up
to that to that a-minus range right so
go ahead and see if you can solve this
on your own and we'll come back together
we'll do it together
okay so basically what you want to do
here is we're still using this average
formula here the average is a total
divided by the number of tests and in
this case your average suit that you
want is 90 so let's put that in for the
average 90 and then the total is going
to be 87
well 76 plus 88 plus 92 okay now the
fifth test we don't know what that is so
we're just going to call it X okay the
unknown divided by the total of how many
tests here now some students will make
the mistake of saying well there's four
tests but now when we add on that fifth
test we have a total of five okay so
then what you want to do now is you're
trying to get the X by itself that
unknown test what you can do is multiply
both sides of the equation by five okay
this is like five over one so these are
gonna cancel one another out five times
90 is 450 and then let's go ahead and
total these up of course you can use
your calculator so let's do that
87 plus 76 plus 88 plus 92 that's 343
okay
343 plus X and of course if we subtract
343 from both sides okay x equals well
let's see what does that come out to
that looks like let's see let's just do
it on our calculator real quick - 343
it's 107 so you would definitely have to
get the extra credit right on this this
last test to boost your grade up to a 90
so again means or averages definitely an
important concept you want to understand
for the AC t